I call President mm Abbas of Palestine
to deliver his
message in the name of Allah the omip
the oh Believers stand steadfast with
patience and fear God so you may
Thrive these are words from the Holy
Scripture your Royal Highness Prince
Muhammad bin Salman Crown Prince and
prime
minister of Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia your
majesties Royal highnesses your
excellencies heads of state and heads of
Delegation may God's peace and blessings
be with
you they believe that their military
might will protect them and intimidate
us yet we are the rightful owners of the
Land
Jerusalem
and holy sites that will remain us
United and the occupation will come to
an end as I speak to you our Palestinian
people have been reing to the most
heinous ferocious
aggression it is not but a genocide War
by the Israeli killing machine that has
been violating the international law the
inter humanitarian law and breached all
red lines as they have killed and
injured more than 40,000 Palestinians
most of whom are women children and
Elders in addition to the total
destructions of thousands of residential
homes on the heads of their
residence this is what happened in one
months what if it remains and continues
thereafter at the same time the West
Bank and
Jerusalem are coming under daily attacks
by the Israeli occupation
forces as well as the terrorist illegal
settlers my heart is heavy with sadness
and with and grieve for the killing of
thousands of children and annihilation
of ttal households destruction of
hospitals mosques Church and schools in
Gaza Strip it defies logic that this is
happening before the eyes of the whole
world without immediate action without
putting an end immediate end to this war
and sparing our
unarmed civilian people from these
atrocities how long will these
violations atrocities absence of Justice
continue against our people I am certain
that you cannot accept nor you nor any
free man in the world would accept these
dual standards or accept that our people
will remain victims to this ethnic
cleansing genoci
War the Israeli occupation forces and
those who
support and protect them are totally
responsible for the killing and the
injury of each and every Palestinian
woman and child the
occupiers will be brought to Justice
before the international criminal
courts even if we have to go to the
corner of the world
and in this context we would like to
point out that the United States that
have the measure impact or influence on
Israel is totally responsible for the
absence of a diplomatic solution and we
call on the US Administration to put an
end to the Israeli aggression the
Israeli occupation and violation and
desecration of our holy sites yes we
call on the United States
Administration Mr
President this is a historical moment
each and one all and each must live up
to his responsibility for the
restoration of peace and security
foundations in the region to avoid
recurrence of
violence and in order to achieve this we
emphasize the following first the
security Council to live up to its
responsibility and obligation to put an
end to this bant war on against our
people without further delay and the
delivery of relief Aid Medical Supply
restoration of fuel electric power to
Gaza Strip and prevention of forceable
transfer of our
gases
our Palestinian fellow Palestinians in
Gaza and West Bank which is totally and
categorically rejected
second no military or Security
Solutions are
acceptable as they have all failed and
the Israeli occupation forces undermined
the two State solution with their
illegal settlement
policies genocide aggression and above
all the just Siege laid around Gaza and
the violation of the historic and legal
status of the Christian and Muslim holy
sides we will hold State fast holding
our ground on our own Homeland and we
cannot
bargain over our established rights we
reiterate that Gaza Strip is part and
parcel of the State of Palestine and the
Diplomatic solution must be inclusive of
all the Palestinian territories
including Gaza Jerusalem and West Bank
and we reject Israel's piracy over our
funds transferred to Gaza Strip on
monthly
bases whom we did not abandon for a
single
day the total budget expend in Gaza
Strip since
2007 exceeded 20 billion dollar it is
our duty it is Our obligation towards
our fellow Palestinians to ensure they
are provided with health education power
water and other basic services in
addition to the salaries of employees
let alone the social welfare we call on
the security Council that
Palestine is granted its permanent
membership and the international
protection to the Palestinian people
provided and this is what we have
repeatedly
demanded yet we are abandoned and left
alone to face the Israeli occupation
forces with their aggression and bent
War we need and we seek International
protection for our unarmed civilian
Palestinian
people on the basis of the Arab peace
initiative to put an end to the
occupation and have the Palestinian
independent state on the
1967 border established and the
Palestinian Refuge issue be resolved
under the United St United Nations
resolutions with an clear mechanism of
implementation this is
what are working on and complied
by the Palestinian Authority the sole
and lawful representative of the
Palestinian
people I call on ring the international
support to enable the Palestinian State
institutions to continue to fulfill
their
duties to support our Palestinians in
Gaza Strip including the rebuilding of
Gaza Strip and to have your resolutions
with regards to to support our budget
implemented in order to Pro
provide the monetary safety
Network endorsed in the previous Summit
mainly at this dire time and also to
provide resources to bring the
Palestinian economy back on its feet at
the earliest and without delay we also
reiterate that we will continue to
implement reform plans across our
institutions and we are willing to have
General presidential and parliamentary
elections across all the Palestinian
territories including Jerusalem to
conclude we thank his Royal Highness the
monarch of Saudi Arabia King Salman bin
ABD and the clown Prince the president
of this Summit Prince Muhammad Salman
the their Royal highnesses and majesties
the rulers and the heads of state for
providing support and solidarity with
our people at this grave hour and I
wouldn't fail to remember to thank all
the peoples of the world who took to the
streets protesting and demonstrating in
support of our established lawful rights
and as we Mark the AR of demise of late
president yat to our people we say here
we stay remain
steadfast and by the grace of God we
will end up
Victorious